il ya quelques années de ça une certaine
époque j'étais dans un cachot sombre à
maison d'arrêt de fresnes et je tournais
dans la cellule puisque on nous retirait
le matelas à l'époque donc on pouvait
que rester debout dans un coin de la
cellule via les toilettes
j'entends quelques bulles moi je me
penche m'approche je regarde qu'est ce
que je vois je vois la tête d'araki sort
qui prend une respiration et qui repart
alors là je peux vous dire que je suis
pas allé aux toilettes tout de suite
donc je me suis retrouvé un moment donné
à me dire que j'étais dans une situation
un peu difficile mais comme j'étais seul
tu sais l'isolément total on est dans le
noir on voit personne
ça faisait quelques jours que j'avais
pas discuté avec un quelqu'un je me suis
dit je vais partager mon pain avec lui
j'ai posé un petit bout de pas au bord
des toilettes
j'ai attendu le lendemain up il avait
disparu
deux jours plus tard pareil la même
chose et finalement le rat a commencé à
être un petit peu apprivoisé et quelques
jours plus tard je me suis retrouvé à
côté de mon amie laura mais je faisais
mes petites confidences et je lui
racontais un peu ma vie et il m'écoutait
était en train de grignoter son petit
morceau pas m'écouter et juste et la gt
j'avais une compagnie j'avais un soutien
j'avais une écoute
c'était formidable bon on arrive au
terme des 45 jours de mitard et il va
falloir se quitter donc on s'est assis
côte à côte
on s'est regardés on s'est fait nos
adieux et je vous assure j'ai vu une
petite larme
des deux côtés et je suis sorti du
mitard je me suis posé la question
depuis mais comment j'en suis arrivée là
et voilà l'histoire c'est que en
décembre 84 je suis avec une copine une
amie ma fiancée de l'époque et je me
fais agresser par une 8,8 skinheads
à l'époque c'était voilà c'était des
gens très violent d'ailleurs le sont
toujours mais bon et malheureusement
j'ai sorti une arme et j'ai tiré parce
que je sentais qu'ils allaient lui faire
du mal
bon j'ai tiré il ya eu un mort et un
blessé
deux jours plus tard je me retrouve dans
un fourgon cellulaire et je pars pour la
plus grande prison d'europe qu'on
appelle fleury mérogis j'ai jamais vu
une prison j'ai jamais vu de fourgon
cellulaire ni vu de cages et d'ailleurs
je ne savais pas qu'on pouvait enfermer
des êtres humains dans des cages
c'était un choc assez assez important et
je me suis retrouvé dans le dispatching
c'est le centre de fleury mérogis où on
accueille les arrivants et là c'est la
première fois je dois mettre à poil
devant quelqu'un première humiliation
ensuite je vais au greffe on dépose nos
nous à faire nos cartes d'identité etc
et on vous donne un numéro et ce numéro
on le garde toute sa vie en mémoire 138
496 qu ensuite on vous lâche en
détention alors la prison qu'est ce que
c'est c'est pas seulement la privation
de liberté et c'est aussi la misère
c'est aussi le manque d'hygiène le
manque de soins la surpopulation pénale
et tout un tas de choses qui sont
vraiment inhumaines et surtout la
violence
on arrive en promenade il faut se battre
tout de suite c'est un univers dur et il
faut y survivre donc bien je suis en
prison je commence ma peine et à
l'époque ces années 80 donc on est en 85
il ya une maladie assez répandue qui
commence à faire
une grande épidémie qui arrivent et donc
il ya les tests qui arrive test pour
savoir si on a le sida ou pas et j'en
fais un et j'apprends que je suis
séropositif donc ma vie commence mal à
partir de là j'ai qu'une chose en tête
c'est de m'évader
parce qu'à l'époque on pensait qu'on
pouvait vivre trois ans cinq ans maximum
et donc j'ai qu'une obsession c'est
m'évader je fais ma peine quatre ans à
fleury mérogis ensuite je suis transféré
et je me retrouve à obtenir une
permission à mi peine parce que bon j'ai
pris dix ans à l'époque et on comprenait
que je m'étais fait agresser mais bon
j'ai pas d'espoir je suis malade je sais
que je vais peut-être mourir demain et
je ne supporte plus la prison telle
qu'elle est c'est de cette façon
inhumaine de traiter les gens je ne la
supporte plus donc je me mets en cavale
en cavale il ya pas 36 solutions pour
survivre en cavale faut de l'argent peut
pas aller travailler
je me mets à voler et je rentre dans un
système de braquages et je deviens
braqueurs je me fais attraper
je prends deux années de deux trois
années en plus et en 93
je fini par sortir en fin de peine hélas
toujours pareil pas de remède pour la
maladie la prison m'avait vraiment cassé
ça veut dire que c'était vraiment un
système qui vous rend violent et qui
vous transforme
j'ai 28 ans là quand je termine ma peine
et je récidive
je reprends les armes et je remonte sur
des braquages et je suis
voilà dans un dans un processus ultra
violent je me fais attraper en 94
je sais que là je pars pour des années
et que je vais mourir en prison
et finalement comme je sais que voilà
c'est terminé pour moi je tente le tout
pour le tout et le 9 octobre 1994
c'est l'anniversaire de l'abolition
à peine de mort j'ai choisi cette date
pour m'évader je fais rentrer des armes
dans la prison et je fais une prise
d'otages et j'ai réussi à sortir je fais
une cavale très violente aussi avec des
braquages des hold up et finalement 95
je me fais arrêter par le raid et home
incarcère et je me retrouve en quartier
d'isolement
parce que je suis devenu un homme
dangereux et un ennemi de la société ce
qui est vrai cinquante quartier
d'isolement c'est voir personne pendant
toutes ces années
isolé total et pour tenir à l' isolement
la seule solution client puisqu'il n'y a
rien c'est de lire et j'ai découvert la
littérature j'ai commencé à lire et j'ai
trouvé dans les mots une façon de
voyager une fois son de et d'écouter le
monde quoiqu'ils dont j'étais privé et
j'ai trouvé ça la force des mots c'était
vraiment quelque chose de puissant qui
pouvaient m'emmener quelque part et me
faire m'évader en fait et après ces
années d'isolement en 2000 en 2095 2000
je fini par sortir et je suis transféré
à la maison d'arrêt de la santé
et là donc je retrouve des gens je
commence et je les touche pour voir si
si c'est vraiment des humains donc je
commence à revivre et je m'inscris à des
cours en prison il ya des profs qui
viennent qui a une université paris 7 et
il ya une section qui s'appelle la
section des étudiants empêchés
c'est pour les prisonniers et là je
tombe sur un prof à prof de philo qui
s'appelle françois chouquet on discute
et il me dit que les mots sont plus
forts que les armes
évidemment j'ai rigolé au début est bien
gentil mais bon bon bref
mais je continue à faire des études
j'ai commencé à écrire un petit peu et
il m'a il m'a fait lire de tolstoï
céline camus à la recherche du temps
perdu comme si j'avais que ça à faire
mais il m'a apporté quelque chose
vraiment c'était vraiment une richesse
et finalement j'ai commencé à écrire un
petit peu et je lui ai montré mon
premier manuscrit 1 et m'encourager m'a
dit voilà enfin j'existais quelque part
dans la société enfin dans j'existais
pour quelqu'un quelqu'un me lisait on
existe en 2002 je suis condamné
définitif et je prends 30 ans 30 ans
c'est long
j'ai de quoi lire trois bibliothèque
françois mitterrand donc bon voilà je
prends 30 ans je prends 30 ans bon je
vais vous dire franchement à ce moment
là quand je les ai pris j'ai été
transféré directement centrale
sécuritaire est bon j'ai tenté de
m'évader encore une fois j'ai pris deux
ans en plus mais bon c'était 7es jeux
bon et comme je pouvais pas supporter de
rester en centrale je faisais des
émeutes
j'ai mis le feu à clermont c'était bon
horrible mais voilà si le parcours
c'était difficile d'accepter de cette
privation de liberté donc j'étais à peu
près à une vingtaine d'années de prison
déjà cette époque finalement 2006 je me
suis dit qu'il fallait que je m'évade de
ma condition d'individus dangereux
devenir quelqu'un d'autre parce que j'en
avais un petit peu marre donc en 2006 je
me retrouve à la centrale de poissy et
là je crée le premier blog d'un détenu
d'un prisonnier sur le nouvel obs le
premier aujourd'hui où tous internet en
mai le premier c'est moi qui les fais où
j'ai expliqué dans des chroniques la vie
carcérale tout ce que je défends des
voilà comment lutter contre un système
qui nous tue enfin bon bref
et puis aussi l'absurdité du système et
d'autres textes des handicapés en prison
etc etc
alors évidemment l'administration
pénitentiaire était contre puisque
c'était interdit
c'est interdit de communiquer ça passe
pas par la censure mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui savent toujours pas
comment j'ai fait pendant quatre ans
j'ai fait passer mes textes sur internet
sans qu'il le sache
j'ai aussi rencontré fabien marsaud un
concert il vient avec ses béquilles
fabien marsaud ces grands corps malade
excusez moi est ce que j'ai aimé chez
lui c'est que grâce à ces mots grâce à
son slam
c'était une personne handicapée ici
levée et il a pu exercer son art donc
c'est la force des mots qui ont permis
ce miracle on va dire pas eu besoin
d'aller à lourdes et il a fait du slam
et il est allé il a réussi à faire une
carrière donc on est devenus très potes
très amis parce que moi aussi l'écriture
me permettait grâce aux blogs et j'avais
édité mon premier bouquin j'étais plus
un individu dangereux je suis devenu un
écrivain et un pigiste pour le nouvel
obs
je peux vous dire que l'administration
pénitentiaire ne regarder d'un autre
oeil
10 et là il se passe quelque chose c'est
pas normal est en train de nous préparer
une évasion quelque chose
je vous assure que c'est vrai je peux
vous dire que même il prenait mon
ordinateur il le vire est passé au clis
et instance pour surveiller les
ordinateurs pour voir si j'ai pas de
connexion etc et le directeur venait me
demander mais c'est vous qui écrivez ça
je dis non c'est un fou qui se passe
pour qui ce fait passer pour moi qui
écrit des trucs vous assure ça passait
et donc grâce à un bouquin que j'ai que
j'ai fait j'ai rencontré jeune étudiante
on est tombé amoureux l écriture amen à
tout donc on est tombé amoureux et on a
décidé au bout de quelques mois de faire
un bébé par loi parce que l'humanité
c'est ça aussi
donc j'ai fait un bébé par loi et en
mars 2008 n'est ma fille
deux jours après la naissance parce que
je suis pas parti tout de suite ils
pouvaient pas j'ai été dans la maternité
un délinquant comme moi je me retrouve
dans une maternité et je vais voir mon
bébé on m'a enlevé les menottes
il y avait une fenêtre je les regardais
quand même mais
c'est parfois c'est plus fort que nous
mais bon et j'ai j'ai pris mon ma fille
dans les bras
[Musique]
et donc on l'a appelée tilelli tilelli
en kabyle ça veut dire liberté puisque
c'est la seule qui m'avait réussi à me
faire sortir de prison au bout de vingt
ans tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai
constitué un dossier pour la
conditionnelle j'ai mis deux trois ans
en béton parce que j'étais papa j'étais
responsable et finalement juge
d'application des peines voyant j'avais
fait 25 ans de prison s'est dit bon il
est peut-être temps que je le fasse
sortir puisqu'il devenu pigiste est
devenu papa est devenu ceci est et j'ai
réussi à avoir mon diplôme universitaire
de paris 7
donc tout ça pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui on pense que les
récidivistes il faut les mettre au
placard et qu'il faut leur serrer la vis
et qui font plus qui sortent
moi je vous prouve le contraire pas avec
mon parcours je vous dis que c'est
possible
le retour à la vie il est possible et il
est possible grâce à des gens et de la
bonne volonté et finalement dans toute
dictature
la première chose qu'on enlève c'est la
culture on la détruit et on devrait même
jugé l'ignorance pour crimes contre
l'humanité
et c'est grâce à la culture que j'ai
réussi à m'en sortir
à la lecture à des profs donc il faut
encourager ce genre de choses et je
repense à la phrase de choc et qui avait
dit que la pluie était plus forte que
les armes et ce avec la plume que j'ai
reçu ma plus belle évasion
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]